the elderly population is growing around
the world according to the UN the number
of people aged 80 or older is expected
to triple over the next 30 years one
consequence of that is more older
drivers getting behind the wheel Japan
with one of the world's oldest
populations is already facing an
epidemic of accidents caused by impaired
older drivers as Lucy craft reports how
Japan is addressing the problem may
provide lessons for the rest of the
world in Japan tragedies like this seem
all too common nowadays an elderly
driver loses control and a busy Tokyo
Street turns to mayhem this accident
last year killed a mother and child
hats strewn on the pavement where their
bicycle was demolished an 88 year old
man has been charged with manslaughter
the victims images have galvanized
Japanese who are saying enough is enough
my wife was still conscious as she was
thrown into the air so the grieving
husband and father her only thought was
surely whether our daughter was safe a
grim new genre of dashcam videos
features seniors driving badly for much
of the Japanese public the country seems
under siege by agent motorists in
fast-growing Japan an estimated one
quarter of octogenarians are still on
the road over the last decade
Japan has seen more than a six percent
rise in fatal collisions caused by
seniors
few cars have collision avoidance
systems so Tokyo now subsidizes
modifying cars to prevent sudden
acceleration when drivers mistakenly hit
the gas pedal instead of the brake
Buddha yoga welcomed this store manager
said if you accidentally slam on the gas
it activates this device which restrains
engine speed so your flooring it now and
it's only gonna go 6 miles an hour no
matter what chastened by the backlash
some seniors are going back to driver's
ed this one-day class was overwhelmed by
demand for four hours they negotiated
traffic cones practice slamming on the
brakes and learn how to ease out of
alleys eighty-year-old makoto da nose
said his wife wants him to stop driving
but he's not ready nun jus then come
I've been driving for decades with no
complaints he said families are being
urged to stage driver graduation
ceremonies to get seniors to give up
their car keys if the Japanese
government has its way senior citizens
will be trading in their full-size cars
for something like this single seat
ultra compact electric cars with a top
speed of 30 miles per hour it's just
enough car for a trip to the store and
far less of a traffic risk Japan is
considering a plan to subsidize
purchases of tiny cars like this one
aimed in part at luring more seniors out
of their sedans for CBS this morning
Saturday Lucy Kraft
Tokyo I like it it's it's tough because
a lot of people you think your
independence is being taken away right
and we should say there's a different
that some 90 year olds are more than
capable and yeah I Drive and others may
have a little more difficult time so
it's a tough issue as the population
ages right you can understand why maybe
you'd want to do more road tests more
frequently when you reach like me right
perhaps maybe they should be mandatory
at a certain age yeah all righty
we solved the problems of the world